[Music]
hey everyone welcome to other
installments of Harry Potter theory in
this video I'm going to be addressing a
question that was requested in the
comment section quite a bit and that is
was Voldemort able to produce a Patronus
this is a good question because even
though Voldemort was immensely powerful
he wasn't necessarily able to perform
every type of magic in order to delve
into this further I'm first going to
explain what a Patronus is in essence of
eternity the result of a witch or wizard
casting the Patronus charm there are two
types of Patronus charms corporeal and
incorporeal the more basic form of the
spell is the incorporeal Patronus which
assumes no animal form and simply
resembles a burst of white vapor or
smoke the more advanced form of the
spell is the conjuring of a corporeal
Patronus the ability to successfully
cast a corporeal paterna's is considered
an impressive feat in a Wizarding
community the corporeal Patronus assumes
the form of the witch or Wizards spirit
animal and varies extensively from which
to which opposite to wizard Harry's is a
stag runs as a Jack Russell Terrier and
Hermione's is not ER etc while casting
spells that create your very own spirit
animal is probably fun there is a
purpose and that purpose is to ward off
Dementors or less of alts dark creatures
that feed on human happiness and incite
a feeling of despair anyone that gets
close to them they are among the Fallas
creatures around and represent nothing
but darkness depression and decay the
Patronus charm is the only known way of
dealing with a Dementor and so it's a
gravely important thing for witch or
wizard to know the Patronus represents
everything that demented doesn't hope
happiness survival and purity as the
Patronus itself does not feel despair or
hopelessness as a human might the
Dementors can't hurt it and are repelled
by its presence which brings me to
Voldemort surely a wizard as powerful as
him with seemingly endless magical
capabilities was able to conjure a
Patronus surely the Dark Lord Himself
would have been able to handle a couple
of Dementors this is where you may be
surprised
the successful casting of a Patronus is
not only reliant on magical ability but
also love and
happiness things that he has no concept
of Voldemort was doomed from the start
and by far as big as floor as a person
is the way that he was unable to fill
love it was the fuel for the fire that
said Voldemort off on his path of
villainy I really wonder what type of
man he would have become if he was
simply able to understand emotion or the
concept of love
he was truly destined for evil and had
no escape Voldemort is just as dark and
evil as a Dementor and so it makes sense
that he would not be able to produce
something that could combat them
Voldemort only joy came from doing
terrible things he was never happy even
in childhood and never got to experience
true love or happiness leaving him with
no concept of either this is perfectly
depicted in a quote from Dumbledore in a
discussion with Harry if there is one
thing Voldemort cannot understand it is
love he didn't realize that love as
powerful as your mother's for you leaves
its own mark when JK Rowling was asked
if Snape was the only death eater who
could successfully produce a Patronus
she responded yes because a Patronus is
used against things the Death Eaters
generally generates or fight alongside
they would not need patronesses
Voldemort and other dark witches and
wizards saw no use for the spell because
they were entirely desensitized to dark
reaches and dark things the spell was
simply not something that made any sense
for them to use or learn who would not
help them so dark Wizards see no use for
casting a Patronus but what happens if
they actually try to do it what happens
if they try to cast the spell there's
actually tale of dark wizard called Rex
ideon that attempted this very thing in
the tale it is stated that Rex idiom he
still he tried to cast a spell failing
to remember that only the pure of heart
can produce a Patronus it was the first
wizard in history to try it and while he
was an accomplished wizard it did not
end well then after casting spell it has
stated that maggots shot out of his wand
which quickly devoured him as they
engulfed his body
ouch so it's pretty safe to say that
Voldemort couldn't and wouldn't ever be
able to produce a Patronus but if he did
somehow cast a Patronus if he could
somehow understand love even if only
briefly then what form would his
Patronus take we know that the form of
patronesses are uniquely tied to
which am wizard the custom when
initially casting the corporeal Patronus
The Witcher wizard will have no idea
what animal they are conjuring until
they've done it for the first time there
was no explanation for how a certain
Patronus animal is tied to a witch or
wizard it is speculated that the shape
of the Patronus produced is
significantly influenced by the
personality of the caster and so when we
see characters with the same Patronus
harrion's father
snippin Lily we can infer they had
similar personality types it is also
worth noting with the corporeal Patronus
of a wizard can actually change
according to life events a Patronus is
recognized as an extension of the
identity of a witch or wizard which
means that in many cases you will know
who is trying to contact you through
their Patronus alone so what was
Voldemort's Patronus surely it must have
been something very powerful and evil
something that could complement his
nature it turns out that a Patronus can
actually be almost anything and the
limits are fairly undefined this is
supported with the following information
from possible no reliable system for
predicting the form of an individual's
Patronus has ever been found although
the great 18th century researcher of
charms professor catalyst spangle set
forth certain principles that are widely
accepted as true the Patronus asserted
spangle represents that which is hidden
unknown but necessary within the
personality here says Bengal is the
explanation for the appearance of
patronesses informs that their casters
might not expect for which they have
never felt a particular affinity or in
rare cases even recognized it is usual
but not inevitable for a Patronus to
take the form of an animal commonly
found in the caster's native country
given their long affinity with humans
it is perhaps unsurprising that among
the most common patronesses although it
must be remembered that any corporeal
Patronus is highly unusual are dogs cats
and horses extinct patronesses are very
rare but not unknown strangely given
their long connection with wizard kind
out patronesses are unusual most
uncommon of all possible patronesses are
magical creatures such as dragons
thestrals and Phoenix's while a rare and
magical Patronus undoubtedly reflects an
unusual person
see it does not follow that it is more
powerful or will enjoy greater success
at defending its caster I'd like to
think that Voldemort Petronas animal
would be a snake this would be a
reflection of volume its relationship
with his companion New Guinea New Guinea
in snake form was first introduced in
the Goblet of Fire where she is
described as eating the body of mogul
Frank Bryce though we don't have an
exact date it's speculated that Nagini
and Voldemort met in the forests of
Albania sometime in 1980s at this point
makini would have likely fully assumed
her snake-like form and Valen would have
been hiding in his disembodied State
it's hard to say how the initial
interaction would have gone but we know
a couple of things about Voldemort that
have helped him in interacting with a
giant snake first Voldemort is able to
possess animals and we know that later
on in the films and books he can possess
Nene as I would imagine that possession
was part of their original interaction
secondly Voldemort is the descendant of
Salazar Slytherin this means that his
connection to snakes is strong and that
even he can communicate with them
because of his ability to speak past the
tongue if we are supposed to be
immediately recognized by our patron
is's then it would make sense that
Voldemort Patronus would be a snake like
Nagini as the two are commonly
associated with one another
additionally Nagini was perhaps the only
person that Wilmore ever seemed to show
some level of genuine affection toward
Dumbledore had this to say a Voldemort
relationship with Nagini
I think he is perhaps as fond of her as
he can be of anything he certainly likes
to keep her close and as an unusual
amount of control of her even for past
month alternatively I think that
Voldemort Patronus could be something
completely over-the-top highly
physically intimidating and very unique
something like a basilisk as we know
from the Chamber of Secrets the gigantic
basilisk aka the serpent of severan was
a creature place inside of the chamber
by Salazar Slytherin himself one of the
four founders of Hogwarts the basilisk
was originally placed there to peel
the school of all muggle-borns and could
only be controlled by the rightful heir
of Slytherin we know to be Tom Riddle
though Harry could speak to the basilisk
with Parseltongue he had no control over
it
throughout the Chamber of Secrets we see
Hogwarts students dropping off like
flies this is because the basilisk is
loosed from the chamber of secrets when
these students were found they were in a
petrified state to be petrified means
that you are basically turned to stone
you're completely immobile and
unresponsive one frightening capability
that basilisk as his ability to turn
people to stone by indirectly looking at
them similar to the old sailors tale of
medusa or kill them by directly looking
at them something as immense and
intimidating as a basilisk just seems
fitting as a Patronus of old Walt
however we have to remember that
Voldemort would never be able to produce
a Patronus as he does not possess the
capacity to feel loved what do you guys
think
what would Voldemort Patronus be let us
know down in the comments section below
and that's it for this video I hope you
enjoyed it if you enjoy the content
please remember to like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
you're a wizard Harry
[Music]